avant d'aller plus loin je devrai
justement à propos de cette faculté qu
on les mettra bien enseigner ou un mal
enseignée j'aurais qu'on regarde un
reportage que nous avons que lauren que
zain réaliser c'est un maître justement
de l'enseignement primaire qui a essayé
de sortir de la routine vous allez le
voir il a fait avec ses élèves une
expérience intéressante ces dernières
années les invités non seulement lire la
poésie mais à l'écrire au même une cour
de récréation comme les autres des
enfants turbulents comme les halls ce
propos mais ici il se passe quelque
chose d'un peu différent
un instituteur et c'est de révéler aux
enfants toute leur richesse d'expression
et de création moyen privilégié des
veilles la poésie sous toutes ses formes
sa recette la liberté en classe les
enfants choisissent leurs ateliers
certains recherchent des poèmes sur des
thèmes qui leur plaisent
d'autres préfèrent comme ici
l'illustration graphique et musicale
grâce à cette imprégnation nombre
d'entre et crises spontanément du ring
et leur plus grand plaisir mêlé leurs
propres vera se dépose
elle avait dû brazeau dans leur coeur a
chanté aussi à la daube et l'humble si
lad
le premier oiseau qui s'éveille ses
chances j'écoute
les jardins sont rémi sans date en
écoute
le printemps est restée cachée comment
toutes les mauvaises années mais
maintenant ils donnent la vie la nature
hier ont dormi
le printemps a éclaté au milieu de mon
énergie des misères ont disparu et les
sourires sont à venir lui autrefois les
maîtres imposer je dirais dans leur
classe une récitation parce que cette
cette récitation eux en tant qu'adulte
il l'avais bien ressenti et il avait
envie que les enfants apprennent cette
récitation
mais on se rend compte que ce qui plaît
à l'adulte ne plaît pas obligatoirement
à l'enfant et l'enfant apprenez cette
récitation d'une manière docile mais ce
n'est pas comme ça que le contact avec
la poésie pouvait se faire je crois que
le fait d'être obligé d'apprendre une
récitation qui ne plaît pas
obligatoirement risque de détourner de
la poésie plutôt qu'autre chose tout ce
qu'on veut on peut rêver puis
le tout marqué c'est est ce que c'est ce
l'imagination on reste dans remarque
tout les et on trouve